as the price of gas and the price of
food rises more americans are turning to
food banks as non-profits help more
people their budgets are taking a hit as
well bianca holman joining us live to
explain bianca so many local families
rely on these food banks
especially individuals on fixed budgets
or families on fixed budgets so that's
why organizations like three square and
united way of southern nevada which is
where we are right now are helping those
people
so prices are up 6.3 percent they're
higher than they were a year ago and one
area that people cut back on is food
leaders at three square food bank tell
us their sites around the valley are
seeing an increase in the need larry
scott of three square also tells us that
while it used to cost twelve hundred
bucks to bring food in from out of state
now that same delivery can cost as much
as five thousand dollars
while purchase food only represents ten
percent of their uh
supply there
the group is seeing an increase in
prices and having difficulty finding
certain items just like the average
consumer
there's just a really fine edge between
those who are
food insecure and those who are not in
many cases
and certainly
an economic hit like this exposes that
larry scott also says that if you're
experiencing troubles reach out and ask
for help three square sites work hard to
provide a dignified and respectful way
of providing food for everybody and so
coming up in the next half hour we're
going to talk with united way about how
they're helping more nonprofits because
of the spike of inflation it's impacting
everybody bianca holman live local now